[Musique]
sic aussi un brin d'émotion de retourner
ici vous retrouver et très belles
transitions finalement dans la poursuite
de ce qu'on vient de voir la question
que moi je me pose c'est que révèlent
ces interactions que l'on a avec les
machines qui nous entourent que l'on a
de partout qu'est ce qu'elle révèle sur
nous humains qu'est ce qu'elle révèle
sur les méthodes qui nous permettent de
les concevoir et qu'est ce qu'elle
révèle sur nous quand on est élu on les
utilise pas de suspense qu'est ce
qu'elles révèlent elles nous aident
elles contribuent à mieux nous
comprendre nous humains et ça c'est
fantastique
au contact de ces machines finalement on
est quelque part
poussé dans une dynamique où on a besoin
de mieux se comprendre pour concevoir
des machines toujours plus instinctive
toujours plus naturel à utiliser et à la
fois on est on est poussé vers des
usages qui sont en train de se
transformer alors je suis ingénieur je
suis développeur je code je crée ses
interfaces depuis de nombreuses années
et puis je suis entrepreneur
j'en ai créé une activité et je suis
papa et en tant que papa j'ai vécu une
expérience bouleversante avec mon fiston
et je voudrais vous la partagez une
expérience pendant laquelle on est
proche des fêtes de fin d'année et puis
j'ai créé un petit programme pour mon
garçon que j'ai installé dans un robot
et puis ces robots il est connecté à une
guirlande qui est dans un sapin
voilà je demande à mon garçon tient
vient installe toi
face à ce robot
je me suis trouvé un poste et après je
veux que sept seigneurs
bouleversant pour le pape ans il a fait
de la magie bouleversant pour le papa
alors là je peux vous dire que j'ai pris
une dose d'émotion en voyant ça et je me
suis posé des tas de questions notamment
qu'est ce que révèle cette interaction
qu'est ce qu'elles révèlent pour monfils
et qu'est ce qu'elles révèlent pour moi
concepteurs de cette solution
alors quand je revois cette vidéo je
peux pas m'empêcher de penser à une
autre anecdote
quelques années plus tôt développeurs
aux codes et puis on fait des logiciels
sur une autre forme d'interaction avec
des machines des écrans et puis on crée
des boutons etc et donc je faisais ça
pour quelque chose de super excitant des
logiciels de comptabilité et là je me
revois en fin de journée après une
journée très riche beaucoup de réflexion
a attrapé un bout de plastique dans ma
main droite qui a eu pour effet de
déplacer une petite flèche sur un écran
pour arriver jusqu'à la zone en bas à
gauche sur laquelle était marqué
démarrer et là je me suis dit mais cette
machine n'a rien compris c'est bien la
dernière des choses que j'ai envie de
faire maintenant de démarrer ce que j'ai
envie de faire c'est de m'arrêter partir
mon fiston il a vécu une expérience
complètement émotionnel complètement
connecté avec cette machine on en a fait
du progrès entre cet écran qui ne
comprend rien de mon état et cette
machine qui a fait vivre à mon garçon 1
étape complètement complètement
bouleversant alors ça ça nous ouvre un
monde d'opportunités
finalement aujourd'hui alternatif on vit
dans un monde où la technologie
plus proche de nous plus simple à
utiliser plus instinctive créer un champ
des possibles qui est juste inimaginable
ce que je voudrais partager avec vous
ces trois petits secrets qu'on a
découvert sur ce que révèlent ces
interactions avec les machines et on va
on va tout simplement les regarder avec
l'oeil du concepteur et l'oeil de
l'utilisateur alors le premier c'est le
concept de l'engagement
qu'est-ce-qui singulièrement a changé
dans les machines que l'on produit
aujourd'hui
et bien c'est précisément cette notion
d'engagement comment ça fonctionne
de quoi on parle entre humains quand on
interagit on cherche un regard le regard
créée une première connexion
je vous donne un peu de mon attention et
vous allez m'en donner en retour
et si je les value si j'ai envie d'en
faire quelque chose de cette attention
je vais commencer à construire une
relation
je vais commencer à pourquoi pas
répondre par un sourire ou carrément
engager une discussion
ça c'est des mécanismes qu'on utilise
nous en tant qu'humain tout temps sans
même s'en rendre compte
figurez vous qu'on a réussi à mettre ça
dans des machines
le concepteur que je suis pense et agit
avec des mécaniques très simple on place
un regard sur un écran vous l'avez vu
avec un robot qui gesticule dans la
vraie vie
la magie opère tout de suite
l'engagement elle est immédiate
instinctive naturel indé challenge que
l'on a réussi à relever récemment c'est
de faire en sorte que cet engagement on
arrive à le faire à partir d'un simple
écran alors ses deux yeux
attention ce n'est pas un leurre on n'a
pas simplement une image des yeux on a
aussi grâce aux progrès technologiques
notamment autour de l'intelligence
artificielle la capacité maintenant de
percevoir véritablement les réactions de
l'utilisateur farseth face à cette
machine est donc le la boucle de
l'engagement
ça y est on arrive à l'obtenir dans la
vraie vie pas mal voilà une première
étape
on sait qu'on est capables d'interagir
avec une machine d'engager une relation
de la même façon qu'on peut le faire
avec des humains pas mal de quoi at-on
besoin
on dit que le dans un message dans une
communication entre humains 20% moins de
20% du message complet passe par le sens
des mots moins de 20% et le reste alors
une des composantes importantes
c'est l'émotion deuxième pilier qu'on a
découvert
l'émotion c'est quoi c'est la capacité
d'enrichir un message d'enrichir une
information et de véhiculer des tas de
choses
alors pour vous en rendre compte très
concrètement comment les machines ont
évolué et aujourd'hui sont capables
d'exprimer des émotions je vous proposer
une expérience qui vous allez voir est
tout aussi bouleversante
je vous présente une forme elle doit
vous rappeler quelque chose cette forme
on lui a donné deux petites choses
particulières on a mis deux manettes
d'accord et puis on va essayer de les
bouger tour à tour
est ce que je vais vous demander c'est
participer avec moi et d'essayer
d'imiter en même temps que moi l'émotion
que vous voyez sur cette forme là on
attaque en bougeant le premier levier on
ressent quelque chose bon là ça dit un
peu moins plaisant on essaie de bouger
le deuxième levier niveau d'activité on
le ressent plus élevé puis là on réduit
un peu plus calme puis cette fois ci on
reste dans cet état qu'on bouge le
deuxième levier ou c'est à ça que sert
la dynamique de l'émotion et les
machines que l'on peut créer aujourd'hui
ont cette capacité d'utiliser ses formes
de manière dynamique et adaptée pour
véhiculer en plus du sens des mots
une émotion de manière instinctive et
naturel exactement comme vous venez de
le vivre maintenant engagement émotion
fantastique un troisième levier que l'on
a développé que l'on a identifié comme
étant un des points clés à à faire
avancer c'est la dynamique
d'apprentissage très simple à comprendre
quand on interagit avec un enfant on se
rend bien compte qu'il a encore des
choses à construire et qu'il le fait
étape par étape en expérimentant le
monde avec ses propres capacités
d'interaction d'engagement et d'émotion
l'engagement c'est le christ et le
pleure l'émotion c'est la récompense le
câlin ou juge est mais jouait par terre
et bien en expérimentant étape après
étape interactions après interactions
l'enfant construit des stratégies pour
être le plus efficace est véhiculé un
message de manière la plus simple et la
plus efficace possible
et bien pour les machines bonne nouvelle
à présent c'est également possible
c'est également possible parce que les
techniques autour de l'intelligence
artificielle nous permettent de
développer et de mettre très
concrètement dans des produits des
stratégies d'apprentissage qui évolue au
fil du temps de pas de recul engagement
émotions apprentissage terminator non
soyons optimistes on a une opportunité
aujourd'hui de créer des solutions
technologiques de façon bienveillante au
service de l'humain centré sur l'humain
pour lequel on doit et on va construire
une nouvelle chaîne de confiance
oui parce qu'il faut y réfléchir un
petit instant ces machines interactive
naturel instinctive avec lesquels on
partage notre quotidien c'est demain
notre smartphone c'est demain des
assistants connectés que l'on va voir la
maison
ces machines là vont de plus en plus
avoir accès à une information
extrêmement intime sur notre quotidien
on parle de nos émotions
on parle des niveaux d'engagement eh
bien on a une opportunité aujourd'hui de
manière résolument bienveillante et
enthousiaste de créer une nouvelle
chaîne de valeur une chaîne de valeur ou
le produit c'est pas nous le produit
s'est pas la donne est gratos qu'on va
filer parce qu on interagit avec ses
machines
maintenant on le sait vous le savez nous
savons et nous concevons ces machines là
doivent être produites et utilisées en
étant conscient qu'on leur donne une
part de notre humanité qu on leur donne
une part de notre existence et donc à
quoi ça sert tout ça
des machines interactive engageante
émotionnel apprenantes pour lesquelles
on a une relation de confiance et bien
moi je me projette avec vous dans des
usages qui sont absolument fantastique
pour nos gamins sur trois sujets
communiqué apprendre jouer avec ces
machines toujours plus proche de nous
facile à utiliser instinctive
communiquer avec ma grand mère que j'ai
oublié de vous présenter devient enfin
possible
elle n'a jamais connu et compris à quoi
servait internet le smartphone pour elle
c'est vraiment une épreuve un appareil
interactif et engageant qui capte son
attention est lui-même capable de lui
présenter une photo de ses petits
enfants
sans même qu'elle est à voir à savoir ce
qu'est une application communiqué voilà
un premier vrai challenge sur lequel on
ouvre le champ des possibles à prendre
et bien là l'idée c'est que on peut très
simplement imaginer des processus
d'apprentissage qui seront très
personnalisé puisque au fil de ces
interactions au fil de l'engagement que
l'on va donner à une machine on va
immédiatement ressentir l'efficacité
d'une stratégie ou d'une autre et les
méthodes apprenantes permettront de
vraiment personnalisé et adapté les
compétences d'apprentissage et puis plus
fun plus léger le jeu bien sûr on va
vraiment se marrer avec des nouveaux des
nouveaux moyens d'interagir et de pensée
des nouveaux jeux avec des assistants de
jeu avec des animateurs de jeux des
maîtres de jeu qui pourront remplacer
ces bons vieux plateau qu'on met sur une
table et être à nos côtés en famille et
nous aider à animer des jeux très
connectés tous ensemble communiqué
apprendre jouer
finalement c'est ce qui fait de nous des
humains
c'est ce qui nous fait grandir en tant
qu'humain et je voudrais conclure sur 7
sur cette vision finalement ou interagir
avec des machines de plus en plus
connectés proche de nous qui nous
connaissent dans notre propre intimité
et dans une zone de confiance que l'on
construit en ce moment eh bien on a face
à nous en miroir un moyen de comprendre
les mécanismes qui nous qui nous anime
est en quelque sorte en les regardant en
prenant un peu de recul et en les
observant en tant que tel on a face à
nous un moyen de découvrir nos propres
mécanismes intérieurs et quelque part de
développer notre propre évolution
personnelle
est ce que ces machines ne serait pas de
manière très objective un moyen de nous
rendre compte que on a des possibilités
d'améliorer notre propre quotidien en
passant à l'action en faisant évoluer
nos habitudes parce que elles mêmes vont
nous les faire percevoir est en quelque
sorte
elles vont finir par disparaître et
mieux nous connecter et mieux nous
servir à nous connecter entre nous j'ai
interagit avec ses machines mais
j'interagis surtout entre des humains
j'interagis donc je suis
[Applaudissements]